with businesses swiftly strengthening
and growing adapting to new
opportunities is highly crucial for all
companies in today's world there is a
continual need for organizations to
improve their business approaches and
stay competitive business analytics
comes into the picture as it can
transform raw data into more valuable
insights to make crucial business
decisions
business analytics is a rapidly
expanding field and the need for
business analysts is increasing with
time knowledge of microsoft excel is one
of the basic skills every business
analyst aspirant must have excel is one
of the oldest and strongest analytics
and reporting tools business analysts
use excel in performing several
calculations data and budget analysis to
unravel business patterns
so if you want to bring about a positive
impact on how business functions in your
organization then nothing can beat a
career in the field of business
analytics get prepared to start your
business analytics career with us simply
learn skill up course provides the best
training in the ever-expanding field of
business analytics the best part about
it is that you can take up this course
for free yes you can begin your business
analytics learning journey with us free
of cost and get a course completion
certificate for the same let us take you
through the details of our free business
analytics with excel posts
simply learn skill up course on business
analytics with excel is specially
designed for beginners who want to boost
their microsoft excel skills the topics
covered in this course are introduction
to business analytics excel analytics
functions excel conditional formatting
analyzing data with pivot tables
dashboarding goal seek tool data
analysis using statistics and power bi
to name a few this free skill up course
gives you a complete overview of how
excel is used in business analytics
the course duration is three hours and
all the modules are self-paced video
lessons with 90 days of access to the
entire course
this allows you to learn at your own
pace at your convenience after finishing
this course you are awarded a course
completion certificate by learn this
certificate can be shared within your
professional circle isn't that great so
now you might be wondering if you are
eligible to take up this course yes you
are qualified since there are no
predefined eligibility criteria to
enroll in this course learners taking
this free business analytics
fundamentals program only need an
analytical mindset and familiarity with
microsoft excel this course is ideal for
students and experienced professionals
alike professionals like it developers
and testers data analysts analytics
professionals and project managers can
take up this course the average annual
salary range of a business analyst is 3
lakhs 16 000 rupees to 15 lakhs rupees
meanwhile an analytics manager's average
yearly salary range is 9 lakhs 45 000
rupees to 34 lakh 6 000 rupees so what
are you waiting for head straight to our
scale up page and enrich your business
analytics and excel knowledge by
enrolling in our free business analytics
with excel course today pack this golden
opportunity and get certified with
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here